can you list off what those
characteristics are absolutely so the
dark triad are three personality traits
that are found in individuals so you
have machiavellianism which is typically
described as sort of manipulation or the
ability to manipulate the second is
narcissism the third is psychopathy so
callousness lying thrill seeking it's
said by psychologists that these three
traits are quite negative but for some
reason they're attractive to women yeah
exactly that evil but attractive yeah
very very attractive so these
individuals it's important to keep in
mind that they're very low in
neuroticism they're very high in
openness they're very low in
conscientiousness very high in
extroversion those characteristics on
their own are pretty attractive a
narcissist smile speaks nicely wears
very nice clothes so that in and of
itself is pretty attractive to women
right a person that is machiavellian is
very disagreeable and what the
statistics indicate is that an
individual that is highly disagreeable
if they are below the mean level of
disagreeability they typically make 18.3
more in terms of yearly income and that
translates to
hundred and about
two dollars per year wow